Hello everyone, this is Jim with Next
Level Commander, and if you're like me
and have been wanting to make vehicles
work since Kaladesh, congratulations,
our time has finally come after just 10
years of wait. Vehicles are really
freaking cool, but they've been for the
most part terrible in EDH. I mean, every
vehicle needs a pilot, and when I
finally get the crew ready, I have to
choose between attacking or blocking,
never both. I once tried a funny little
deck with Narset where I crewed vehicles
into vehicles into more vehicles, and
flying crane technique to go in for
alpha strike, death by conflict tricks.
It worked once, but uh yeah, it was
mostly a meme. With Marvel Legends,
however, we are now in a different era.
Turns out among all these crazy legends,
the most interesting is actually an
uncommon, and what a card this is,
Captain America. Whether it's vehicles,
mana dorks, or the captain himself,
after assembling the deck immediately
after spoilers and doing some testing, I
can confidently say this is the best
vehicles and spacecraft commander, and
it's not close. Yeah, screw throwing
frisbees, we are driving the Reaver
type. I mean, look at this board.
Yeah. Drop Captain, and this entire
board is online, even the spacecraft.
How did that work? Well, we use the land
the factory to pilot the aerial
surveyor, and the surveyor pilots the
Skysovereign, the Skysovereign pilots
Reaver Flagship, and Flagship stations
Uthro's, the research craft. Oh, and all
the pilots are untapped, including the
factory. So then, we can use the Captain
and the factory to finish charging our
spacecraft, and we still have the
Captain untapped, and the Uthro's was
never tapped, so when it attacks, it has
pseudo vigilance. So yeah, offense and
defense all covered. Crazy stuff,
whether it's a Gundam, a planet, or your
mountain bike with flat tires, Captain's
got you. Well then, let's take a look at
our vehicles. So the game plan for this
deck is beat down, so the aggro vehicles
are the core of our deck. Starting with
the classic Skysovereign Consulate
Flagship. Now, this is the old and
probably half of the motivation for
people trying to make vehicles work
since Kaladesh. Flying, solid stats,
convenient crew cost, and the ping
ability does help pick off utility
creatures. Along with that is Consulate
Dreadnought. Now, this is a bit of a
difficult include for most vehicle
decks, but with Captain, this is very
easily crewable and it's another nice
target for Urza's Saga. And after that,
we have just a casual three mana six
hits trample ward, the mighty servant of
Lukka. And it's got a cool ability. You
have to crew it with two creatures. Now,
this is not difficult to do with Captain
America and any other creature. We can
get there and the draw is sweet. We do
need more card draw in this deck. And a
new vehicle in Mobile Module. Solid
card, decent stats, crew two is
convenient and the ability does help us
snowball, which is needed in an aggro
deck. And a few heavy hitters from the
Warhammer universe, Thunderhawk Gunship.
Yeah, this ship brings in pilots for
itself and some extras to spare. That's
always welcome and giving everything
flying is essential for closing out
games. And Knight Paladin, such a cool
card, very aggressive, easy to drive,
what's not to love? And finally, Reaver
Titan, the final boss of vehicles and
one of the most exciting cards in the
deck. And that's not it. We have a few
colored ones. For example, the Pride
Wind Steel Flagship. Yeah, with this,
every vehicle, every artifact mana rock
we draw makes a two two, which is
actually four four usually. Vela's
Flagship is brilliant in this deck. It
does everything. It's a vehicle when we
need a vehicle and it makes a bunch of
pilots when we have vehicles. And
finally, the top end, the dream,
Parhelion II. Just casually pooping out
zero angels. And after this, we have the
utility vehicles. Now, they're called
utility, but they I mean, they're all
vehicles, so they can do solid beat down
as well. Starting with ramp,
Cultivator's Caravan and Cargo Ship are
excellent mana dorks. Meanwhile, Aerial
Surveyor and Regalia will get us
reliable lands. And finally, the omen
kill, which is a personal favorite. I
mean, it does have a front side, but
it's not super relevant because this
ability is great. It's not exactly ramp,
but hitting with this and a few other
vehicles just once and we have lands for
rest of the game. For card advantage, we
have Smuggler's Copter and the
Weatherlight, excellent for digging us
into more vehicles, but nothing beats
the Indomitable. Now, this is a
ridiculous card. We get to draw per
creature and it recurs itself.
Definitely one of the best cards to get
in the early game. And you can't forget
about Shorikai, probably the single best
vehicle there is, mostly because it's
not really a vehicle. I mean, that
ability is just so good. It gives you
cards and a token. Like, how often do
you want to attack for eight rather than
just getting value? Like, I know we
should be attacking, but it's it's just
so hard to resist. It's very difficult
to crew for the average pilot, but
things are much easier when you have
Skysovereign and Parhelion II in the
cockpit. And then we benefit from
Captain America's ability, so we can
both draw on our turn and draw again at
the end of turn. Yeah, I'm sorry. This
card is like the perfect test to see if
you are a genuine Timmy or just
pretending to be. I feel every time. And
just a few pieces of Ensoul Artifact as
we are a bit short on that. Possession
Engine is excellent. It takes a
creature, makes it kind of useless, but
remember, you do keep the activated
abilities. And if they happen to be a
strong tap ability, we are cooking.
Search for a mech will probably kill
whatever creature or planeswalker you
want. And the unlicensed hears to keep
the graveyard in check and it will be
huge later on. Salvation Engine is
excellent pump and recursion and an
Improvise mech which can be anything.
The planeswalker classes is a staple for
any vehicle stack and it's like a backup
version of our commander. And finally,
the Mechtitan Core. Now, the primary
function of this card is a protection
spell for our vehicles. For five mana,
we can protect four of them. Although
the token we make is, I guess, decent in
a pinch. Like, I wouldn't usually
proactively make the token because with
Captain America, the four vehicles can
usually do more damage. But say we need
a life link or something like that.
Yeah, we can make the token. But for the
most part, again, it's for protection
and reusing some ETBs on vehicles. And
that's it for the vehicles. But we're
also going to include some spacecraft.
They just work so well with this deck.
And I mean, when you crew a vehicle and
then use that to station a spacecraft,
it's just such a perfect curve. And with
the ability of Captain America, even the
most demanding spacecraft can be charged
within a turn. Starting with Youth
Rolls, a draw engine that is also an
excellent attacker and blocker. And next
up, we have the Don Sire. Something like
this is way too greedy for 99% of decks.
Even the EOE precon, I mean, I've seen
the Kilo player trying so hard to make
this work. It doesn't. But here, it's
perfectly reasonable. And finally, the
Extinguisher is like a removal and a
board wipe. Kills Captain,
unfortunately, but yeah, just a cool
card to play. Now, we don't have a ton
of choices for spacecrafts, but we do
have Star Trek coming up, and that will
definitely shake things up. Okay, and
that was the core of the deck. Seeing
all these sweet cards should be reason
enough for you to build the deck, but
the deck does need some extra help
because honestly, I feel like the
vehicles could use a bit more pushing,
especially on the top end. I mean,
looking at these, they're cool, but
imagine these being just creatures with
these stats and abilities, they wouldn't
even be that pushed. And again, imagine
these being creatures, just dropping
this on turn five, this on turn six, and
turn seven, you're probably not winning
games, not even in bracket two. So, to
speed up pressure, we're going to need
ramp, lots of ramp. Now, specifically,
what works with Captain America are
these cards, the creatures that tap for
mana. If we drop one of these on turn
two, we can drop Captain and a four-drop
vehicle on turn three.
And the turn after that, we have eight
mana. And of course, these ones are the
best. And oh yeah, if you have a
Metalworker, put that in. These ones are
a lot weaker, but I'm still playing them
over the Arcane Signets and Fellwar
Stones because synergy. We have two cost
reducers in Sid and the new Shuri. Now,
the cost reduction is great, but the
abilities are also really useful. Oh,
and also these two, I heard they're
okay. I don't know, might need some
testing. The only non-creature ones are
Sol Ring and the Eternity Elevator
Station 20, easy peasy. For other
utility, it's pretty typical for a deck
like this. We have card draw, lots of
card draw because we are depleting our
hands fast, and we happen to be in blue
for a mana draw seven, no problem.
Simulacrum Synthesizer is ridiculous.
With this, every vehicle now comes with
a pilot, and they are massive. And also,
Lita, Mechanical Engineer. This card
does everything we want to do and can
just make two vehicles for eight mana.
Now, because we are a vehicle stack, we
don't have a lot of creatures. So, we
are playing five board wipes that only
hit creatures. And also these ones, they
can keep Captain America around. Yeah,
these are basically all one-sided board
wipes. We clear the board, then crew the
vehicles, and finish the game. But,
speaking of finisher, of course there's
the one and only Akroma's Will. Yes,
even in a vehicle stack it's ridiculous.
For lands, the only utility that really
stands out are these creature lands, the
Mishra factories, the Mutavaults.
Because these ones, you turn them on
with Captain America on the board, it
can crew twice or crew and then tap for
mana. Well, that's a neat little synergy
there. Aside from that, we have the two
planets. I mean, they're they're cool.
Yeah, they're just really fun to turn on
cuz it's not that difficult for us.
And these ones that have artifact
synergies,
an Urza's Saga can get Sol Ring or a
Consulate Dreadnought. And there you
have it, Captain America. The deck is
kind of explosive. I mean, it's supposed
to be aggro beatdown, but the vehicles
are not cheap even with all the ramp we
have. Now, the advantage here is that we
can dodge a lot of board wipes that
would ruin most other aggressive
creature decks. And also, we're in blue.
As long as you have ramp and card draw,
your deck can't be too terrible in the
late game. It's fairly straightforward
to play. Now, the crewing takes a bit of
fiddling and figuring out, but it's
actually really fun. Right. And the
budget is mid.
It It can be much lower. I don't I mean,
you don't really need a Metalworker.
Now, this deck technically is bracket
two, but I think it's better suited for
bracket three. I think so. But, it does
depend on your local group. For game
changers, I I guess Ancient Tomb is
always good. Teferi's Protection is
helpful. But, aside from that,
yeah, it's your pick. Wandering Splinter
Twin, whatever. But, yeah, that's it.
Thank you for watching the video. I do
have a sponsor in Kakapopo TCG. They
have excellent, beautiful products. Take
a look at their stuff. And I do have a
discount code, levels all cap, for 5%
off.
And that's all. Yeah, the new set is is
looking good, looking good. I'm looking
at a few legends, so I'm looking to
build some pretty interesting and
unique. Now, I do try my best to test
these decks before making a video
because, you know I want to make sure
these actually work but the time is
definitely limited. I mean this was
spoiled what two days ago. I did get
about five games in with this deck and
it's it's a blast. It's a blast. So
yeah, this is something I think you can
build with confidence especially
considering the upcoming sets.
Okay, that's all. I will see you in the
next video.